representantes de 175 países se reúnen
este lunes en la sede de la UNESCO en
París para definir elementos de un
futuro acuerdo internacional ilegalmente
vinculante para reducir la contaminación
por plástico en el planeta es la segunda
de cinco rondas de negociaciones que
conducirán a ese instrumento regulador
del ciclo de vida del plástico su
producción usos racional y reciclaje las
discusiones de esta ronda tienen como
desafío conciliar dos posiciones con
intereses No necesariamente alineados de
un lado la llamada coalición de alta
ambición formada por medios centenar de
Naciones propone reducir drásticamente
la producción de plástico virgen y tiene
como objetivo terminar con ese tipo de
contaminación en 2040 del otro lado
países dependientes de ese material o
altamente contaminantes como Estados
Unidos India o Arabia Saudita están más
enfocados en perfeccionar el reciclaje
esa contradicción ha puesto en Guardia
al ejecutivo francés cu de transición
ecológica pidió a los participantes que
posiciones como la de Washington no
reemplacen el tema esencial a su juicio
la producción y la reducción de la
dependencia de ese material el propio
representante estadounidense formuló
declaraciones no muy bien recibidas por
activistas medioambientales que aún
resuenan en los medios franceses según
el funcionario de su país espera una
regulación flexible que permita a los
países implementar a su conveniencia y
pidió no diabolizar el plástico con esas
asperezas por limar inicia este ciclo de
sesiones que terminará el viernes se
espera que con una decisión sobre el
enfoque del futuro acuerdo que verá la
luz en aproximadamente dos años